you know on the flip side of how you
make
a union work i can't think of anyone
sort of
um you know and ruth bader ginsburg who
i've just spent the last
week voraciously studying and
if you're watching her documentary
gloria steinem comes up and gloria
steinem is one of the great
world changers game changers and when
she came
up into your world how fast was it
before you said yes to
portraying her oh man it was immediate
i mean julie taymor contacted me about
it and i was like yes absolutely i would
love to be a part of this
i don't think it was after it wasn't
until after that that i really thought
about what it would entail
she's so iconic and she's so meaningful
to
to so many people and has been
emblematic i think of the women's
movement in the united states
so i i i also didn't realize how how
challenging would be because she
is um she's kind of a she's actually has
a kind of a quiet
uh recessive quality sometimes she's
she's known as one of the world's great
listeners
so it's not a very active thing to play
as an actor you know
and her speech pattern is is um is her
and her accent is very
unique and but she's not um she's
someone who will kind of step
back and and and promote other people
and their activism and their and their
words and so
it was it was very very challenging
but but so fantastic just like you know
trying to absorb who she was in that way
i think
for as much as i care about everyone and
i'm such a people person
not sure i'm comfortable in the silences
i definitely
am a good listener but i'm a huge talker
also
and these women they just possess sort
of an
inner confidence which is so admirable
but what they do with it is all this
outward protection of others
absolutely one of the things that really
struck me about gloria is that she's not
reactive you know she's not rash i mean
people said
really horrific things to her they just
they just loaded it
on on her and she um she always came
from a point of like i said she would
listen
she'd wait and then she would respond
but she never responded with any kind of
heat she always responded with intellect
and she wasn't cruel you know to anyone
ever
and incredibly tolerant of other
people's views so i do think about that
i mean i really think when i'm talking
to people i'm like what would gloria do
how would she react how
um you know maybe you know take take the
time to be more like her
you're not going to want to miss this
movie you know julie taymor does direct
and she's such a visionary and she
really is
this film is no exception i think that
gloria's are dissected
in ways that are very unprecedented and
new
and unique and there's an incredible big
surprise ending
that you won't want to miss and really
quickly dear evan hansen
i know that's how i feel oh my god are
you excited
i am so excited i'm beside myself i
honestly i
i can't believe it it's really um yeah
i i can't believe it happened this story
i also
feel is just so important for people
we talk about mental health we talk
about all these issues now that are
trying to be
more in the forefront and on the table
and then ben platt
a role he seemed born to play
and for a lot of people watching the
play was the moment everything really
like clicks is his relationship with his
mother and you'll be playing her and i'm
just
i'm so excited for this to you know
have everyone have access to it oh i
feel so
lucky and and it really is a beautiful
beautiful piece and and i think it will
make a wonderful movie
i think so too and i have just the
biggest pom-poms rooting you on always
and thank you so much for greasing our
show with your presents
the glorious will be available streaming
on amazon prime